okay so what is going to happen next so
right now basically the hopes of the
republic lie with joe manchin
the democratic senator from west
virginia the only reason that joe
manchin is still
in the senate in west virginia is
because
he is a very right-wing democrat meaning
he has
institutionally allied himself with
left-wing members of the republican
caucus pretty often people like susan
collins and lisa murkowski
he also happens to be an
institutionalist in the in the mold of
john mccain
which means that he is anti getting rid
of the filibuster and he is anti-packing
the court here is joe manchin
not all that long ago saying that he is
not going to stand in favor of killing
the filibuster or expanding the supreme
court
i commit to you tonight and i commit to
all of your viewers and everyone else
that's watching
i want to lay those fears i'm going to
rest those fears for you right now
because
when they talk about whether it be
packing the courts or ending the
filibuster i will not vote to do that
i will not vote to pack the courts i
think and i will not vote to end the
filibuster
brett this system the senate was so
unique body in the world
it was made to work together in a
bipartisan way and once you start
breaking down those barriers
then you lose every every reason that we
are the institution that we are the most
deliberate body okay so so watch for joe
manchin to absolutely be shellacked by
the left i mean
every day the pressure is going to be on
joe manchin because so many of the
democratic hopes for their legislative
priorities
rest in ramming through everything with
51 votes or 50 plus kamala harris
so if the filibuster is still in place
you need 60. to break the filibuster you
need 60 votes
so without killing the filibuster what
exactly can be done and this is
this is why realistically speaking biden
is not going to get most of his agenda
here so that's that's a comfort right
just on a legislative level that's a
comfort because what biden would wish to
ram through
and what he is capable of ramming
through are two very different things
okay the the process that he is going to
use is a process called budget
reconciliation
okay budget reconciliation is there's a
certain area of american law
and senate procedure in which 51 votes
or 50 plus the vice president to break a
tie
that that number of votes is necessary
only in order to pass particular
budgetary items
so you can't for example pass amnesty
through budget reconciliation now
he may not have to pass amnesty through
budget reconciliation right he may
actually have the
votes for amnesty like this is the thing
that i'm most worried about on a pure
legislative level
there are really three things that i'm
worried about on a pure legislative
level
from joe biden with his new senate
majority which is just unthinkably bad
here are the three things i'm worried
significantly about tax increases
because of budget reconciliation which
i'll explain in a second
i'm worried about immigration because i
think there are a lot of soft-hearted
republicans
and uh and in some cases soft-headed
republicans who are going to try and
revive the 2013
immigration deal that would not only
legalize the so-called dreamers but
would actually legalize 11 million
people
minimum who are in the country illegally
right create a quote-unquote pathway to
citizenship for them
and and get very little in return
because there are a lot of republicans
out there who still believe
that if they're soft on immigration
somehow this is going to shift latino
voters in
into their into their aisle i i don't
see the evidence for that
at all donald trump actually
outperformed with hispanics compared to
for example
mitt romney in 2012 romney was very soft
on immigration
or at least more soft on immigration
trump was very harsh on immigration and
very openly harsh on immigration and he
did much better in 2020 with hispanics
than he did in 2016. so the evidence
that republicans would be making a smart
electoral move by signing on to some
sort of giant amnesty bill that
legalizes
what is really not 11 million it's
probably closer to 20 million people who
are in the country illegally
that that seems like bad politics to me
but it doesn't it would also not be hard
i think to peel off enough republicans
to defeat a filibuster there so
that is uh the top legislative priority
that is likely to receive some sort of
bipartisan negotiation for republicans
because republicans are afraid of the
issue even though they really should not
be
even though there actually is a pretty
wide consensus in the united states what
to do about immigration
which is make sure people don't come
into the country illegally if they do
come into the country illegally
then you deport them if they've been
here for a very long time then you
determine whether they ought to remain
in the country based on whether they are
of benefit to the united states or
whether they are not
right everybody basically agrees on that
by pulling data but republicans
i think might well sign on to some sort
of amnesty bill because they've done so
in the past
so i'm worried about tax increases i am
worried about immigration
and i'm worried about the public option
because democrats did use budget
reconciliation
to pass obamacare right they did use
this process they twisted this process
to use budget reconciliation okay so
what is budget reconciliation and it's
going to get a little obstructive
but it's important you got to know these
rules because these are the rules
democrats are going to use
if mansion doesn't cave on the
filibuster now if mansion caves on the
filibuster it's all over right
i mean the country is basically toast if
mansion caves on the filibuster and if
the democrats get rid of the filibuster
in the senate
then they would move immediately to make
puerto rico and washington dc states
which would add four senators they would
immediately move
to pack certain federal courts right
they would be able to ram through with
51 votes extraordinarily radical
legislation on everything from the
so-called
green new deal to the so-called equality
act
but assuming that the that the
filibuster holds
then what they're going to be able to do
probably is amnesty
because again i'm not sure that
filibuster will even hold for amnesty
i think they'll be able to do tax
increases through budget reconciliation
probably the public option okay so what
is budget reconciliation
so vox did a did a rundown of this and
this actually happens to be a fairly
decent rundown
talking about what budget reconciliation
is they did this back in 2019
reconciliation was designed to make sure
the united states senate could pass
easily bills dealing with the federal
budget particularly if congress wanted
to reduce the deficit without the threat
of a filibuster from the minority party
the process begins with a congressional
resolution instructing committees in the
house and senate
to draw up legislation that saves the
federal government a set amount of money
so the special privileges under
reconciliation come with conditions
right
the goal here was to have the budget not
be held up by filibuster every single
time
and so there is a rule that was created
that you could pass a budget with 51
votes but
certain conditions that needed to be met
a bill passed under budget
reconciliation is forbidden from
increasing the federal deficit outside
a 10-year window so you have to wait for
the cbo estimate
remember that republicans did this with
the with the trump tax cuts right they
passed that through budget
reconciliation
and then they waited for the cbo to say
that it wasn't going to raise the
deficit outside of 10 year window
there is also something known as the
byrd rule the rule came about in the
1980s
after west virginia senator robert byrd
grew frustrated with budget
reconciliation because
his colleagues were using it to advance
all sorts of stuff not just stuff
related to spending and revenue so there
there's a new standard for what can be
included in a reconciliation
bill this has been enshrined in federal
law so it has to
check all of these boxes in order for
you to be able to pass it with 50 votes
plus kamala harris breaking the tie
every time i say that it just makes me
want to spin my head around
like uh like the lady from the exorcist
and vomit everywhere just cover the
entire studio and vomit kamala here is
breaking ties in the senate unbelievable
un-effing believable okay so here is
sorry sound engineers here is the um so
here is the the bird rule okay
these are the tests for the bird rule
one the provision must change federal
spending or revenue
okay so it can't just be on an unrelated
topic like the equality act which is
about
regulating transgender bathrooms and
such two
if the bill does not meet the budget
resolution's instructions to reduce the
federal deficit
any provision that results in either
increased spending or decreased revenue
is removed
until it does meet those targets so any
budget that is passed under this is
supposed to be revenue neutral
right this is why you remember that they
totally game the system on this with
obamacare so they came up with these
bull crap explanations of how obamacare
was going to be revenue neutral even
though it actually costs
the country over the years hundreds of
billions of dollars minimum
three the provision must only affect
policies that fall under the
jurisdiction of the specific committees
that were instructed in the budget
resolution
four the provision's effect on spending
a revenue must be more than incidental
to its policy impact so in other words
you can't say
yeah we did a bill on transgender
bathrooms and that has a budget impact
no it's got to be like the primary focus
of the bill it has to be very very
central to the bill five
the provision cannot increase the
federal deficit at some point in the
future beyond the typical 10-year budget
window that is used to evaluate
legislation
and six the provision cannot be used to
change social security right that was
enshrined to make sure that republicans
didn't use
budget reconciliation in order to shore
up social security
so for health care bills number four is
the real problem because again
the health care bill could be argued to
to really not be about the budget at all
now democrats have usually gone to the
rule makers in the house the senate
parliamentarian
and said okay well you know what it
actually isn't incidental and then
rammed things through
it does create a problem for things like
medicare for all for example
it could be a problem for for the uh
for for the public option that joe biden
is attempting to push
it could also not be a problem for that
so
budget reconciliation is the way that
senate democrats are going to get things
done
that is going to take off the table
things like the green new deal that
radically raise the debt
radically raise it it's going to take
off the table
things like the equality act thank god
because the equality act is really
dangerous
it's by the way again joe biden when it
comes to immigration reform
my concern is that republicans are going
to cave on immigration reform i mean
biden has said over and over and over
again he wants comprehensive immigration
reform here he was during the campaign
saying that
on day one i'm sending no matter what
the state of this is
to the united states congress a bill to
provide for a path to citizenship
for 11 million undocumented people
number one in the united states
number two every daca student will be
able to stay
it's a gigantic objective of mind
to see to it that we make a we have an
immigration system
that's consistent with our values and
who we say we are okay so he really
wants to push that right and we'll see
if republicans cave on it this is where
the republican base is going to need to
stand up on its hind legs and say no to
its own senators if those senators try
and ram through some sort of crappy
amnesty bill
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content